bonjour à tous et à toutes
et merci un merci particulier à celles
et ceux qui ont fait la route ce matin
très tôt pour venir à ce rendez-vous en
disant ça je regarde ma christine dalloz
députée du jura qui me confiait tout à
leurs cassettes élevé à 5 heures du
matin et qu'elle avait fait l'aller
retour dans l'autre sens pour pouvoir
dormir une nuit chez elle cette semaine
je sais que c'est le cas de beaucoup
parmi vous on vous demande beaucoup en
cette période d'élections régionales et
c'est pas fini
donc merci vraiment à tous et et en
particulier à ceux là qui sont souvent
sur les routes
oui on peut les applaudir au conseil
national en même temps vous serez pas
déçus parce qu'on va passer un bon
moment un conseil national c'est un
moment fort c'est un moment fédérateur
c'est le plaisir d'être ensemble et de
se retrouver et c'est une force dans le
monde moderne et c'est notre force nous
sommes nous demeurerons un parti
profondément populaire
c'est dans nos gènes c'est dans notre
adn
bien sûr il ya la numérisation en marche
et ça ils changent rien et d'ailleurs on
le constate à l'occasion des
consultations en ligne que tu as voulu
lancer nicolas
elle renforce notre sentiment
d'appartenance plutôt qu'elle ne crée de
la distance entre nous et notre
mouvement politique et elles sont à
chaque fois un franc succès le conseil
national c'est aussi un rendez-vous
statutaires et avec tous ceux qui ont
participé avec moi à la réforme des
statuts
nous avons voulu laisser au conseil
national
sa place d'instances la plus importante
juste après le congrès le congrès tous
les militants le conseil national c'est
notre parlement interne
ce matin nous formons le parlement des
républicains nous votons le budget nous
l'avons voté bravo danièle nous validons
aux contenus des programmes et des
projets nouveaux tours de plus en plus
souvent en ligne pour ça et puis surtout
aujourd'hui
nous donnons et nous avons donné les
investitures et je voudrais insister
d'un mot plus particulier sur ce point
le fait que le conseil national donne
les investitures
c'est la meilleure réponse à toutes les
polémiques
si la meilleure réponse aux attaques sur
les investitures qui serait le fruit de
collusion locales pour certains de
petits arrangements nationaux pour
d'autres ou l'un vers ce qu'on sait pas
très bien elle au statut ils sont clairs
ils organisent l'élection par tous les
présidents pour tous les militants d'un
président qui s'engage il est là il fait
vivre il fait respecter les règles et
puis le président auprès de lui un
conseil national
et je crois pouvoir dire ce matin que
nous sommes tous d'accord j'ai vu le
carton bleu pour demander que partout et
par tous les règles soient appliquées et
soit respectée et singulièrement par
celles et ceux qui sont venus chercher
notre investiture nous le leur demandons
ce matin très clairement l'investiture
aux élections c'est ici que ça se passe
la commission nationale d'investiture a
bien travaillé que la sarkozie je peux
en témoigner à gérer personnellement
avec diplomatie et fermeté les
situations les plus complexes
oui un peu
et christian estrosi qui a été là tout à
l'heure à la tribune qui a rejoint
maintenant premier rang s'est démené
pour trouver des solutions d équation
impossible et je propose qu'on
applaudisse avec lui et autour de lui
tous ceux qui ont participé à ces
travaux difficiles pendant des jours
christian il a donné de son temps de son
énergie alors qu'ils mènent une bataille
difficile sur le terrain il est comme
vous tous mais mais il le fait c'est
vrai avec une énergie particulière
totalement engagés à la fois dans la vie
de notre mouvement politique et dans
cette campagne lui en l'occurrence dans
sa campagne qui est particulièrement
importante mais dans cette campagne
maintenant qu'on a donné les
investitures on est dans la dernière
ligne droite pour les régionales
ces élections sont une épate une étape
importante et nous revient de le
partager le plus possible avec les
français qui parfois non non ne sont pas
encore complètement convaincu pas tous
si une étape importante ces étapes
importantes notamment sur le chemin de
vérité ce qu'elle nous sommes engagés
pour en finir avec le mensonge
socialiste le mensonge
hollande ici aussi ça commence là la
gestion socialiste des régions n'a rien
à envier à la gestion socialiste du pays
les régions elles auront été le
laboratoire de recherche du hollandisme
au pouvoir elles auront été le lieu où
ils auront testé toutes leurs erreurs
l'explosion de la dette partout
l'explosion des impôts les dépenses de
fonctionnement le recrutement toujours
plus nombreux de fonctionnaires
territoriaux et puis dans le même temps
le taux de chômage record et notamment
le chômage des jeunes
tout y est et c'est le thème de notre
prochaine table ronde
oui il faut mettre fin à tout ça et en
même temps nous ne pouvons pas ne devons
pas compter sur le simple mouvement de
balancier qui conduirait à l'alternance
c'est à nous de faire pencher la balance
et de démontrer nos capacités nous
devons pas non plus penser que tout sera
facile
une fois que nous aurons retrouvé le
pouvoir dans les régions et au niveau
national je l'espère en 2017
parce que
les choses ne reprendront pas leur cours
comme au soir du 6 mai 2012 monde a
changé
la crise s'est approfondie la france a
emprunté de mauvais chemin et nous
devons aujourd'hui non seulement
préparer la victoire mais préparer la
suite c'est ce que nous ont notamment
avec les journées de travail et tous les
débats qui sont organisés et tous les
débats à venir
j'en suis sûr dans l'année qui vient
face à nous les socialistes les
extrémistes sont dans des calculs et des
postures l'intérêt du pays
manifestement ils comptent peu ou pour
rien ils ont des manières de
manipulateur d'hommes de coûts et
surtout pas d'homme d'état on a le
sentiment que poursuivre et
politiquement ils sont prêts à tout nous
entraîne dans le très court terme qui
est leur horizon et si c'était seulement
une incapacité ce serait navrant mais
c'est une volonté c'est du cynisme et
gère les drames ils se complaisent dans
l'émotion certains cherchent à se
tailler un costume présidentiel mais
l'émotion
sipa l'action et c'est encore moins
l'anticipation la réponse c'est nous et
républicains qu'il apportons c'est nous
qui pouvons la mettre en oeuvre c'est à
nous de faire savoir le plus fort
possible que dès les prochaines
échéances que la gauche et les extrêmes
sont des impasses comme ils disent et
christian l'instant pour la france pour
la nation pour l'état c'est dans nos
rangs que la démonstration peut être
fait et doit être fait qu'on peut encore
espérer la politique la politique c'est
pas un gros mot et la politique c'est
pas un vain mot
non on n'a pas tout essayé c'est à nous
de démontrer démontrer qu'on peut aimer
la france fait respecter son état sa
nation être inventifs créatifs adapté au
monde qui bouge et à la société
française qui bouge
nous portons un espoir pour la france et
les français nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
devons pas les décevoir
pour la france et les français et pour
le monde
parce que la france est regardée dans le
monde demain je serai au liban avec les
réfugiés de syrie ils attendent aussi
notre message notre force notre
engagement
ouais
ils attendent ils attendent beaucoup de
nous et leur plus cher espoir n'est pas
forcément devenir absolument chez nous
leurs espoirs sait aussi que nous
prenions notre part dans ce qui leur
permettra de rentrer ou de rester chez
eux c'est aussi ça le message de la
france
mes chers amis nous avons plusieurs
responsabilités réussir les élections
régionales dans nos territoires sont le
coeur de la france et ils seront le
pilier de la reconquête réussir nos
primaires dans un puits sans exercice
démocratique de bonne humeur et de bonne
volonté de tous côtés et réussir pour la
france et pour les français
faux merci